[Music]
welcome to the Houghton library at
Harvard University I'm standing in the
entrance hall and behind me is the door
to the reading room where with proper
introductions you can come and look at
some of the most beautiful books and
manuscripts and objects you can imagine
there are various exhibition spaces I'm
standing in one of them there are others
upstairs but what I'd like you to see
with me is an exhibition that a seminar
at Harvard has produced that shows
Harvard's collection of medieval Scrolls
these are the scrolls that are talked
about in this module and so this
walkthrough of the exhibition can serve
us as an introduction to medieval
scrolls and to the scrolls in this
module or it can serve as a summary of
all the things that you may have looked
at in more detail in each of the other
units so in the largest of these
exhibition rooms the Edison and Newman
room we have laid out a collection of us
almost all of the scrolls that belong to
Harvard University the good news about
this whole thing is it provides a
wonderful representative sampling of the
kinds of Scrolls that survived to us
from the Middle Ages you'll see some
interesting things about scrolls in
general in this exhibition for one thing
a display case of this size isn't the
perfect way to display something that's
30 feet long so the majority of these
scrolls have to be kind of rolled up at
the ends which of course is how scrolls
are mostly used when they're long
nevertheless it makes it hard to examine
the whole thing so it's made an
interesting choice for us we've had to
pick what part of each scroll should be
shown to the people who go through you
lucky people have the opportunity to
examine all the surfaces of all these
Scrolls because they've all been very
carefully digitized by the Harvard
libraries
there's a number of things that jump to
the eye when you see these things in the
flesh in the parchment as it were one is
that they very enormous ly in size on a
computer screen everything's about the
same size but look at this great big
scroll here this is a universal
chronicle this is the only one that has
had to be displayed sideways because
it's wider than the display case itself
but it's a very handsome and very wide
this is the biggest of the scrolls we
have here and on the wall behind it is
this tiny little poetical scroll that
looks you can see to look at it even in
its frame that it was once folded but it
seems originally to have been a scroll
and is a poetical dialogue so very large
- very small but there are other things
that it's possible to notice - like
qualities of parchment look at this
handsome white parchment here and some
of the others you'll see much darker
very beat-up we also go from Scrolls
that are quite simple this is a scroll
in Greek with very little decoration two
Scrolls that are very highly decorated
this is a genealogy of English kings
that has almost more pictorial elements
than text to this very beautifully
decorated scroll of prayers with
decoration around the top and the
left-hand side almost as though it were
the left hand page in a codex you kind
of wonder why there's not decoration
down the right-hand margin and I think
it's because the decorator knows how you
do a decoration you go in the outer
margin in the top but nobody will know
for sure and then there's this scroll
here this very sad scroll this is a
chronicle and you can see that it once
had very beautiful pictures which are
now faded and that some great scholar no
doubt wanting to improve human knowledge
treated the text of this thing a hoping
that it would be possible to read it
better and the result has been to make a
mess of the parchment and of what was
once a very very beautiful scroll so the
variety of things that we see here and
the difference in types of parchment
size of scroll level of decoration level
of use and where all those things are
something that you can only see when
you're sort of walking through this
exhibition and looking almost touching
these very beautiful objects in this
module we talk about four kinds of
scroll not really kinds of scroll but
four reasons for making a scroll in the
Middle Ages when the standard way of
conveying a text was in a book in a
codex so I think we have in way examples
of almost all of those kinds of scroll
in this exhibition and looking at them
in those categories will allow us either
to introduce or to summarize the other
more detailed units that we've had one
reason for making the scroll is when you
don't know how long the scroll is going
to be until you're finished one that's a
little bit like that is is this scroll
over here this scroll is a legal scroll
and in a way it might be thought of as
the kind that could be extended as more
information as needed in fact it's a
copy of a treatise a treatise by a man
named Glanville about how to run a court
how to produce writs various kinds of
things and it is in the style of scroll
that in England was called a Chancery
role that is one that's made like all
these other roles by making it longer by
adding an additional piece of parchment
to the bottom of it the distinction was
made in England because other kinds of
Scrolls and this group of Scrolls here
is sort of the other way of making rolls
these are manor court roles they are
roles that record the legal actions in
the courts of English manners because
the lord of the manor was officially a
judge and his judgment was recorded in
rolls this kind of roll called Exchequer
rolls is made by stacking the parchment
up on top of each other and binding it
together across the top rather like a
kind of a flip chart in a classroom and
then rolling them up so big ones of
these are sometimes called
pipe rolls because they looked sort of
like a pipe so it's a very different
kind of roll from any of the other roles
we'll see here of this particular kind
of scroll so it could get longer as you
like but you do it by stacking the pages
up rather than adding them to the bottom
and so it's not really a roll it's
really a codex except for the fact that
they were stored rolled up so one kind
of scroll is the kind whose length is
not known
another reason for making a scroll is
when you want it to be portable when you
want to carry it around for in one place
to another and this little scroll on the
wall here is an example of that kind of
thing this is the smallest scroll at
Harvard it may not be the smallest
medieval scroll there is because there
were lots of other times when you wanted
something very small you might want a
life of saint margaret to wear around
your neck you might want to have a
little scroll of prayers that you
carried with you as a kind of an amulet
this one is actually a poetic dialogue
it's a fairly important text it's a
dialogue between Ganymede and Helen
about whether the love of men or the
love of women is better and you can see
along the sides the different characters
as they speak it's a scroll that once
was folded probably was intended to be
rolled and held in the hand while
reciting we know that actors very often
had a role actors still play roles and
the reason what actors do what's called
a role is because they held their part
on a role in their hand this is not
exactly an actor's role but it's the
kind of very small thing that poets are
often depicted as holding in their hands
and that we know actors did so the idea
of having it be small so it can be
portable there are other kinds of
portable scroll not all of which are
illustrated in this exhibition
sometimes a processional music for
churches you don't want to carry the
whole great big gradual around with you
so you write the necessary stuff on a
scroll to go carry carry around and
bless the crops or bless the different
churches of a city across the way here
is another scroll that we might think of
as being in the portable category
it's a series of prayers that are
designed to provide you time off from
purgatory this is a very beautiful
scroll and you can imagine that if if it
were rolled up it would be a little bit
smaller than this so it might be a nice
thing to carry around it might once also
have been hung on the wall or down low
for you to kneel down and pray but if
you say all these prayers you see that
they almost all begin with o if you say
all these prayers you get X number of
hundreds of years off in purgatory you
can see this scroll and hear it
discussed in one of the other one of the
other units but it seems clear that it's
small so that it can be carried around
because it's an object of personal
devotion